you have a question yeah um since you  guys are experts um what eye do you look  at in a person  what the [ __ ] you talking about when  you're talking to somebody both eyes  both i have two eyes one eye is on the  other eye you know what i mean  no way  you can't look at both you can look at  both it's impossible  right now where are you i swear to god  i'm looking at both i'm looking at both  yeah yeah i'm looking  at both eyes right now yeah i'm locked  in i'm locked into i mean i can see the  other eye but i'm locked into your  left what  are you on your [ __ ] mind i know what  you mean does that do you know what she  means oh i know what it is don't say  it's a filipino though  i didn't say it  you but you know what i'm saying